he wanted to be the very best like no
one ever was and only took him a couple
decades to do it Ash ketchum's career as
a Pokemon trainer has been more shocking
than his Pikachu in anime It's Not
Unusual for young male protagonists to
be voiced by women this is a case in
popular anime like Naruto one piece
Hunter x Hunter and of course Pokemon in
both the Japanese and English versions
Ash is voiced by a few different women
he's played by Rika Matsumoto in the
Japanese version While Veronica Taylor
Sarah NATO Jenny and Casey Rogers have
voiced them in English dubs I Ash
Ketchum I came from Pallet Town in the
Kanto region and this is my good buddy
Pikachu nice to meet you in addition to
voicing Ash Taylor and NATO Jenny have
also voiced his mother Delia along with
other characters and Pokemon thus an
impressive feat considering how
different the two characters sound the
other characters Taylor and NATO Jenny
have voice like Ash's traveling
companion May and the gym leader Skyler
respectively also sounds nothing like
him Roger's voice Dash in 2006 is The
Mastermind of Mirage Pokemon Special
versus also provided voices for a number
of Pokemon with their own distinct cries
like Mr mime and Jesse's Wobbuffet
since the Pokemon anime is based on the
Pokemon video game series it makes sense
that Ash has a lot in common with the
protagonists from the games in every
generation of the video game series the
player characters receive their starter
Pokemon from the professor of their
region battle their Rivals and share the
same goal of becoming the Pokemon
champion this is also the case for ash
who gets his Pikachu from Professor Oak
battles it out with Rivals like Gary and
Paul and participates in tournaments
with a championship title on the line
perhaps the most specific similarity
between Ash and the video game
protagonist is that with one exception
they don't have a father figure around
just as Ash always has his mother Delia
to come home to the video game
protagonist can always visit their
mothers in their Hometown however it
remains a mystery where all of the
fathers are the only exception is in the
third generation games where the
player's father is a petalburg gym
leader Norman one of the most memorable
parts of the Pokemon anime comes when
Ash meets Misty in the very first
episode while being attacked and chased
by a flock of Spiro Ash rushes to get
Pikachu and himself to safety and gets
caught on Misty's fishing line instead
of properly introducing himself Ash
shops Hunter missed his bike without
permission and speeds off toward the
nearest Pokemon Center
[Music]
[Applause]
spoiler alerts the bike never gets
properly returned Pikachu ends up
destroying it while attacking the Spiro
flock with a powerful electric move
unfortunately for bike owners on the
Pokemon Universe this is not a one-time
thing for Ash and Pikachu the same thing
that happens to Misty also happens to
several of Ash's other friends in the
first episode of Pokemon advanced
Pikachu zaps May's bike along with Team
Rocket likewise the second episode of
Pokemon Diamond and Pearl sees the
destruction of Dawn's bike during a
battle with Pikachu if it has two wheels
and pedals it probably won't last a day
with Ash and Pikachu around hey what
happened to your bike what happened to
my bike you happened to my bike you
little loser as someone who dreams of
being the very best ashimus faced off
against the toughest Pokemon trainers in
every region that might be easy enough
to do in the video games with enough
experience points but it's no easy task
in the anime between Gym Battles and
tournaments Ash actually loses is quite
a bit in fact Ash loses his very first
gym battle in episode 5 the young
trainer rushes into the Pewter City Gym
and challenges brought to a battle
without proper preparation Roxas Onyx
wraps its massive Stone body around
Pikachu and immediately forces Ash to
surrender later in episode 14 Ash and
Pikachu suffer a demoralizing loss to
Lieutenant search and is Raichu that
almost convinces the 10 year old to
evolve His companion the most
humiliating defeat however comes during
the hyped League battle between Ash and
his friendly rival Richie at the end of
the Indigo League Arc Ash puts his faith
in his powerful yet disobedient
Charizard to defeat Richie's Pikachu but
Charizard lies down and refuses to obey
because of this ash loses the match and
is eliminated from the Indigo Plateau
conference entirely in addition to
losing a few Gym Battles on the Kanto
region Ash also acquires some of his gym
badges in ways that don't really seem
fair to other trainers the fact that
this happens more than once tyrell's
ashes Kanto Journey makes us question
his true talents as a trainer and takes
away from his early achievements after
Ash loses to Brock for the first time he
trains up his Pikachu and challenges a
rock type gym leader to a rematch this
time Pikachu defeats Brock's Rock and
ground type Geodude with a single
electric attack which should technically
not be possible since ground types are
typically immune to Electric attacks
when Onyx is on the field the sprinkler
conveniently goes off and weakens Onyx
to the point where Pikachu's attack is
enough to bring it down Ash ends up
showing Mercy to the Onyx and abandons
the match earning him the boulder badge
along with Brock's respect another
unconventional gym Victory happens with
asha's rematch against Sabrina and a
cadabra in episode 24. just like their
initial fight Sabrina seems to be in
full control however the battle is
interrupted by the mischievous Haunter
who shows up after following ash from
Lavender Town the Haunter Goofs around
making Sabrina and her cadabra laugh
until they are deemed unable to battle
by default ashes declared the winner and
receives the mosh badge maybe you should
just quit now besides the badges you do
have you got out of pity a badge is a
badge
since the beginning of his journey Ash
has captured many different Pokemon some
of which turn out to be incredibly
strong members of his team with a little
bit of training the best example of this
is Ash's first fire type caused as a
Charmander it evolves into Charmeleon
and then Charizard and it receives
special training at characific Valley to
this day Charizard is still considered
one of Ash's strongest Pokemon
unfortunately many of Usher's other
Pokemon don't get the same amount of
attention or training to become that
powerful this is the most evident in the
fact that Ash has a lot of Pokemon that
aren't fully evolved including Totodile
bay leaf and of course Pikachu Pikachu
has expressed a lack of interest in
evolving but that doesn't mean Ash can't
evolve his other Pokemon to make them
stronger while many people who play the
video games tend to evolve their Pokemon
pretty quickly Ash doesn't seem to mind
keeping his companions in their smaller
less powerful forms in the Pokemon
Universe every species has an extremely
rare color variant known as a shiny form
for instance a shiny Gyarados is most
mostly red instead of its usual blue
color while a shiny Psyduck is blue
instead of yellow many Shiny Pokemon are
noticeably different from their normal
forms but some are pretty difficult to
identify some particularly bad offenders
like shiny Pikachu and Shiny Gengar are
just slightly different shades of their
normal colors Ash has one Shiny Pokemon
knocked out for somewhere between
noticeable and subtle at first glance
Ash's knocked out can probably fool
anyone who isn't familiar with the
species since the shiny variants are
normal variants both have brown color
schemes however when Ash is knocked out
a side by side with a normal noctow the
difference is clear ashes knocked out as
a much lighter body and copper toned
wings while the normal Noctowl is darker
overall
since his 10th birthday Ash has put all
of his time and effort into becoming the
best Pokemon trainer he can be he
focuses heavily on training and battling
and doesn't usually show much interest
in anything that isn't related to
Pokemon including romance but despite
Ash's lack of interest and experience in
the love Department a few characters
have taken an interest in him as Ash
travels through the Kalos region he's
accompanied by his childhood friend
Serena it's revealed in episode 6 and 7
of Pokemon the series XY that the two of
them met at camp where ash helped and
encouraged Serena during a difficult
time since then he's held a special
place in her heart and has been a source
of inspiration for her although she
hasn't exactly had the same effect on
him
I can't say I remember you
[Music]
Serena gives Ash a kiss before passing
ways with him in one of the most
unexpected moments in Pokemon anime
history in addition to Serena Ash has
won over the heart of one Pokemon in
particular chicoriza might have acted
stubborn and tough in the beginning but
the grass type Pokemon is ultimately
swayed by the boy's kindness she gives
him a kiss on the cheek when he asks if
she'd like to join him on his Adventure
once chickarita evolves into bay leaf
she develops a habit of tackling her
trainer out of love and excitement the
Pokemon anime wouldn't be nearly as
exciting without some chaos but it's not
just Team Rocket that's causing trouble
throughout Sashi has Many Adventures
mischievous Pokemon seem to be naturally
attracted to him whether these
troublemakers are causing problems
around town or just messing with their
trainers it's always up to Ash to handle
it there are two notable instances where
Ash befriends and captures the leader of
a villainous Pokemon group the first is
the infamous Squirtle Squad that
initially helps Team Rocket kidnap
Pikachu in episode 12. after realizing
who the bad guys really are the squad
works with us to defeat Team Rocket and
puts out a forest fire the leader joins
Ash's team while the rest of the
Squirtles become firefighters a similar
group of Sandile appears in episode 3 of
Pokemon Black and White where they act
out in an attempt to get everyone away
from dangerous geysers Ash eventually
sees their good intentions and they all
work together to get everyone to safety
the leader of the pack follows Ash
around in various episodes before
officially being caught later on after
evolving into Croco Rock despite
remaining 10 years old throughout the
many seasons of the anime Ash's
appearance has definitely undergone some
changes Ash always looks the same
throughout the Kanto and Johto Iris both
alterations after that mostly come down
to New Clothes pads and an upgraded
Pokedex those changes in appearance are
fairly subtle up until the series
Pokemon sun and moon when Ash arrives in
the alola region more than just as Alpha
gets a makeover there's a huge shift in
art style which results in Ash having an
overall younger appearance he even
ditches a fingerless gloves previous
obviously considered a key part of his
outfits then in Pokemon Journeys Ash
gets bigger irises in his eyes to make
him look even more youthful perhaps the
only physical features that always say
the same for ash are the zigzag markings
on his cheeks that look like Pikachu's
lightning bolts after traveling through
region after region Ash finally Stags
his first championship title in the
Manalo Conference of the alola region in
episodes 46 and 47 of Pokemon the series
sun and moon Ultra Legends Ash's final
battle against his rival gladion starts
out pretty balanced Ash's mel-metal is
taken down by Glady and silvalai who is
then knocked out by Pikachu after that
Pikachu faces down gladion zorawak and
they both use their Z moves to take each
other out this leaves gladien and Ash
with just one Pokemon each coincidence
or not they both put their faith in
there too lycanroc at first it doesn't
look good for ashes like and maracas and
struggles to deal with the other lichen
Rock's counter-attack but thankfully Ash
comes up with an unconventional strategy
to secure the victory
counter against counter no way this
gives ashes like and rock enough
momentum to deal the final blow what is
exciting to watch Ash's strategy play
out the win isn't as satisfying as it
could have been in the video games a
counter cannot actually be counted
itself making Ash's use of it not feel
totally legit this isn't the only time
the anime breaks the rules that the
video games have established and it's a
shame that it happens in the
all-important battle that crowns Ash as
the new Champion while Ash may not have
the best track record when it comes to
putting together a solid team of six his
Squad and Pokemon Master Journeys is
undeniably powerful featuring Pikachu
Lucario Gengar Dragonite drakovish and
surfetched surprisingly all these
Pokemon are in their final Evolutions
with the exception of Pikachu in this
case it works out for Pikachu as the
electric Mouse has a special gigantomax
form that Raichu doesn't aside from
Pikachu Ash has two of the strongest
Pokemon from Kanto in his Corner Gengar
and Dragon Knight Gengar is a speed
glass Cannon and another potential
gigantomax option while Dragonite is a
bulky and reliable Flying Dragon Ash
also has a great Mega Evolution in
Lucario this Lucario has shown the most
growth on the team by starting out as an
egg in Ash's care training hard as a
little Riolu and evolving into a total
Powerhouse the gala Duo dragonvision
surface should not be underestimated
either despite their somewhat silly
designs